normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government here
we go from the post millennial breaking
all January uh six footage publicly
released by house Speaker Mike Johnson
I'd like to just pause and say dude why
on a Friday come on on a Friday we know
why he did it he had to do it this shows
they really didn't want to do it but
okay fine it finally happened do you
think it's better to do it on this
Friday considering next week is like if
you did it on Monday it's a it's a
that's the perfect time to do it
absolutely it's Thanksgiving dude next
week we are not going to be here
Thursday and Friday we will have a
culture War episode up Friday but this
is the perfect time to drop on a Tuesday
right before Thanksgiving so when
everyone is at their home with their
liberal aunt that can be like what do
you mean all the footage just got
released here it is now to be fair to be
fair you can still do that no one's
saying you can't but uh it doesn't hit
the press the same way so he could have
released this earlier in the week but
fine so be it now uh this is the this is
the big news Mike Johnson says today I'm
keeping my promise to the American
people and making all the January 6
tapes available to all Americans bang
There It Is take a look at this we got
it all baby it's uh right here at ch.
house.gov subcommittee blah blah blah
blah blah the link has been uh uh
published online by tons of people on
Twitter and uh we've got some of these
clips hey here you go here's a video of
a police officer shaking a dude's hand
as as they're walking through the cops
clearly don't care anybody is here
they're not asking anybody to leave now
I understand that in some circumstances
people were fighting with police yep
those violent people should be arrested
in charged I understand in some
circumstances the cops are on camera
saying guys you need to leave totally
get it however the point is a large
majority of what happened happened well
after the violence on the other side of
the building and the police not only
allow it to happen but we
actually look people they were allowed
to leave they walk right in in right out
there was no effort At All by any of the
officers to stop this and you you want
I'll tell you this right now as someone
with experience in fact I think in this
video you've got a guy where there's a
video where someone gets his Cuts uh his
cuffs removed I don't know if I have
that one pulled up actually but uh
actually yeah was it this one let me see
if it's this video right here no maybe
not just a cop shaking some guy's hand
it was a shorter one let me let me tell
you about uh uh protests in New York
City in Washington DC how about this in
Washington DC on January 20th 2017
around
215 far- leftists were all caught by the
police and arrested as a single group
what did the police do stood in a circle
around them that's it they stood in a
circle around and said you're not free
to go and what did everyone do stood
there you mean to tell me the
insurrectionists are in the building and
the cops are like here you are sir the
exit is Right This Way shakes his hand
takes a selfie and now they're going to
criminally charge these people the best
example as I mentioned earlier is from
Des doza's police state documentary it's
not the best example there's several
examples where a woman says her nephew
showed up an hour after so the doors are
open there's no barricades there's the
the cops have let everybody in and he
walks up and he's like hi how's it going
come on in apparently he walks around
and then he leaves and they've given him
all of these charges they want to lock
him up forever I met a woman who said
her and her husband showed up an hour or
so after all the violence to this exact
story there were no barricades they'd
been removed the doors had been uh
propped open by the police the police
had waved people in and they showed up
waving little Flags having no idea what
was going on now they're being sent to
jail over this was there was there any
uh followup to that reporting from a few
days ago about those buses that
allegedly had like Undercovers ghost
buses yeah it was that was that verifi
okay no the media is calling that one a
conspiracy theory okay well maybe it is
well no are you are you joking it means
in 3 months that'll be proven true oh
right Ian come on what are you doing
here just like the Wuhan ofy we'll
figure out about you know shortly look I
I mean I think that anybody that's
followed this story closely has known
for since day five after j6 that this
was uh largely overblown so I'm not
exactly surprised but I I just hope that
this helps in bringing Justice I would
like an explanation from Johnson the new
speaker as to you know what was the hold
up I would like to know actually from
the the the old guard why why did it
take 2 and a half years for us to get
this information it seems so obviously
necessary that we get to see it I feel
like there's been people in Congress
like there's enough information where
you can kind of say yeah the federal
government is behaving outside of what
is legal right like it's pretty clear
that they're using you know false pre
pretenses to punish political dissidents
and punish people for their political
agendas and I don't know why there
aren't more people in Congress that are
actually saying it there's a handful of
people that are actually talking about
it but most of them don't actually want
want to make a firm statement about the
violations of the law and violations of
of American Americans rights that the
current Administration is is doing I
have a thesis for you go please by me my
my thesis would be that uh people you
know representatives in Congress or in
Senate have watched the FBI worked
surreptitiously to try and undermine
Donald Trump I mean they they tried to
impeach him twice off of totally faulty
information you had uh false affidavits
that were filed by FBI agents these
people are scared to death of speaking
out against the the you know FBI CIA the
entire uh intelligence agency apparatus
and I don't blame them but we need
courage right now that's the problem is
that these people are just not being
courageous and that's what we've
actually put them there to be everyone
on the January 6 subcommittee should be
expelled from Congress agreed they they
they lied manipulated to steal political
power and the sad thing is we all know
it we've always known known it and these
changes will not come however that being
said the the uh uh what happened in
Israel has really been a lightning bolt
on this country a a a a an earthquake of
such such tremendous magnitude the left
is ripped to shreds and seeing these
people say they're going to vote for
Trump we'll get into this a little bit
later but I'm actually more optimistic
than I've ever been when I see hardcore
never trumpers being like I'll vote for
the guy really now I got to tell you
something really crazy about that
January 6 was supposed to be an
Insurrection where they tried to
overthrow the United States and take it
over and now you've got people not they
don't care anymore because of Israel
again I know I know we we'll get into a
little bit later but my point is when it
comes to January 6 subcommittee their
goal was Insurrection they sat in those
committee hearings withholding
information lying about what was going
on why to steal political power that is
an Insurrection that is seditious
conspiracy and these videos only prove
more of what we already knew the cops
are waving people in and shaking their
hands right how can you call that an
Insurrection but it it doesn't actually
begin then it it began I I mean it may
have even begun earlier than this but
the the most obvious example to me is
when you have you know the spying that's
happening on the Trump campaign before
he's even elected president you know and
you have Obama yeah and that was
directed by Obama and Hillary Clinton um
but you know Biden also it was riding
shotgun for much of that so it it just
seems absolutely bizarre to me that the
the representatives in Congress aren't
willing to actually speak out about how
perilous these circumstances are you
know you know what Obama they're not
addressed Obama understood what hurt
Nixon and uh you know what hurt Nixon
the press and so Obama said if I am
going to commit a engage in a seditious
conspiracy after murdering American
citizens and bombing children other
countries he said if I am going to try
and steal power and destroy the United
States uh uh uh govern government and
this country and the lives of the
American people I will have to own the
Press before I do it m and the reason
why he has not been he has not gone down
as one of the worst Presidents in
history is because the Press has just
kept lying in his defense but I truly
hope I hope that within seven within
eight years the narrative has flipped on
the horror that was the Obama
Administration The Psychotic deranged
and evil things that man did let's just
talk about the killing of Abdul Raman
alaki let's talk about the extrajudicial
assassinations of several others let's
talk about the National Defense
authorization act indefinite detention
provision in which Obama said he had the
right to take you in secret in the
middle of the night to an offshore
military vessel a naval vessel and
torture you that's it that's the a
decree he made he prosecuted more
whistleblowers and journalists on the
Espionage Act than any other president
and he spied on Donald Trump working
with Hillary Clinton we know this and
still he gets he gets pass all this why
he owned the Press well and he also won
a Nobel Peace Prize for nothing for
nothing to top all that off he was given
a Nobel Peace Prize win but but let let
let me just add one more item that's you
know in my wheelhouse as to reasons to
not like uh Barack Obama he was
responsible for the executive order that
implemented diversity Equity inclusion
in every Federal uh Department across
our government that was his his action
the last month of Trump's presidency he
tried to undo it and then the very first
day of Biden's presidency they redid it
that's how that's how important this is
to them that they are able to uh
essentially divide and conquer which is
exactly what Dei is even though it's
about diversity right but really what it
is is about oppression Olympics and it's
dividing and making us all you know
become at each other's throats it's
terrible why did Trump wait till the end
of his tenure to do that I couldn't tell
you yeah he could have done at any point
I think I think Tim's right he doesn't
know what he's doing unfortunately which
is why I like V so much because I know
for a fact he understands EX exactly
what I'm talking about man it is it is
I'm I I I I I'd love to imagine a v
ramaswami presidency day one but I you
need more than just unfortunately you
need more than the knowhow to win a like
right to win right and and VI may be the
best day one he goes in with a scalpel
an obsidian blade and just perfectly
perfectly excises all of the rot and
helps turn this country around I mean
but winning is something different I
know and and I think Trump is clearly in
the cat bird seat if you will to to to
win again but um you know I'm still
holding out hope that if it if vake uh
you know broadens his Horizons and he's
willing to consider a VP slot with Trump
I I think that would be probably as good
as I could hope for in terms of a
winning ticket that would actually
deliver much of what the Libertarians
would like to see not not all of it
obviously but much I'm just I I just
like to see people get fired me too
brother I'd like to then see after that
some criminal prosecution yes thank you
yeah I mean there's there's this uh you
know misunderstanding about Libertarians
and anarcho capitalists that like we
don't want you know we don't believe in
the state so we don't want to see
criminals put in behind bars like
couldn't be further from the truth like
you can't speak for all Libertarians
they get pissed off when you do that
kind of stuff well I'm going to do it
anyways uh don't really care they can
get mad at me uh yeah I think if there's
one group of people that all
Libertarians agree ought to be behind
bars it's corrupt politicians that are
ruling over us against our will you know
from jump well Phil would you agree uh
well I'm not a Libertarian but uh no but
from your perspective in your opinion
you said people don't like talking for
Libertarians but you think Libertarians
want to see the corrupt politicians
locked up I think that there there is
the most uh if there is a rule for the
state then policing corruption is
probably among the the most fundamental
things that the state should have to do
I mean you don't want a state that's
that's passing a lot of laws anyways you
you want to let you want to keep laws as
local and low impact as possible um but
if you've got people that are in trusted
with uh with creating law then I think
that the policing of those people is
among the most important that a state do
I'd like to point something very
important out you know these videos are
not the only videos we have proving the
capital police were aiding and abetting
the January 6 Insurrection there's
videos of them opening the doors there's
videos of them waving people in there's
a video of one of them wearing a Maga
hat and waving people in there's a video
of them shaking hands now there's more
videos of them shaking hands releasing
people from Flex cuffs giving them
directions to insurrectionists and the
most important thing the Capitol Police
have been expanded under the Biden
Administration into new locations which
would mean the Capitol Police the
principal and most powerful organization
involved in facilitating the January 6
Insurrection have been given more power
by the Biden Administration which would
mean Joe Biden himself is engaged in an
Insurrection by aiding and abetting
insurrectionists and therefore is
disqualified under the 14th Amendment
fire him that's some uh Fanny Willis
judicial work there I don't care I want
to see the F paperwork look if they're
gonna if they're going to claim Donald
Trump did this that or otherwise it's
all Bs nonsense I just gave you all your
novel legal Theory roll with it file the
lawsuits yes they're losing but do it
anyway the uh you had Lauren Laguna on
your show last week and made she made an
interesting point that sometimes you you
people are guilty of crimes you don't
want to prosecute them for the
betterment of society like that's a
legal philosophy and there are times and
places when you would not prosecute even
though they've done something wrong I
thought that was interesting considering
our current political Paradigm and the
whole tit fortat I'll get your guy and
in four years you're going to get me and
then four years after that someone's
going to come and get you back like
maybe there's a see this is the problem
with that cuz I am a very forgiving
person and I'm also Buddhist meditating
type like yourself so uh the the issue
that I have is that it's not Tit for Tat
it's One Direction give me give me an
example like a real example of a
Democrat who plays ball with the
establishment that actually sees like
hard time Behind Bars it's very rare
it's very very rare um so the issue is
not so much that you know the GOP is
being persecuted it's that the the left
is never being persecuted so if that's
the case you don't have Justice at all
well to be fair Eric Adams uh in New
York you know he gets upset about
immigration so what happens oh the feds
come crashing down because he didn't
play ball right right uh and I mean
that's that's really startling because
you know he was the mayor of New York
City right is the mayor of New York City
is is sorry I'm already Assuming he's
out um but yeah I mean we've got two
three million illegal immigrants that
are coming across the border many of
them are are making their way to New
York and their infrastructure is you
know basically being overran and and
he's doing doing his job but just
because that goes against the the kind
of neoliberal narrative about open
borders and that uh immigration at any
magnitude is acceptable well then you
can't talk about it thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net